the hit musical dramedy Glee continued
the long-standing Hollywood tradition of
hiring older actors to play Teenagers
although none of the actors playing high
schoolers on the show were the age they
were supposed to be they still
apparently suffered from a fairly common
Affliction that plagues all young people
Acme this didn't sit well with the
producers who paid an unnamed visual
effects company to do what was dubbed a
pimple pass on most episodes to ensure
every actor's skin was blemish free
because if there's anything that's going
to make a show relatable to young people
it's Flawless looking actors with
Perfect Skin complaining about being
unattractive